في الوقت الراهن في اكثر من لاعب كبار او
لاعب او يعني لاعبين كبار بيواجهوا
اتهامات بالاقتصاد مثلا عندنا البرازيلي
دانيال مسجون ووضعوا في قضيته او وضعه صعب
صراحه في قضيه نادي كما نتخلى عنه وفسخ
التعاقد مع فورا اول ما طلعت القصه وفي
طبعا اشرب حكيمي اللي ناديه للان في صف
وداعمه ولسه بيتمرن معاهم وضمن التشكيله
والنادي طلع بيان بيدعمه فيه وبيقول انه
معه حتى تتحقق العداله لكن حتى قبل البس
وحكيمي في اكثر من لاعب سبق يعني واتهموا
ونوديهم تعاملت مع القصص خلينا نقول بطرق
مختلفه على سبيل المثال وليس الحصر مثلا
عندنا
ومع انه لاحقا اسقطت التهم عنه لكن مع كدا
النادي للان بيقول انه مستقبله في النادي
مو مضمون المصري امامكم الان على الشاشه
عمرو ورده لما اتهم وكان بيلعب اليونان
النادي استبعدوا واعروا لنادي برتغالي
والنادي البرتغالي بعدها بثلاثه ايام وعلى
خلفيه اتهامات تحرش استبعدوا ورجعوا لنادي
اليوناني المقصود نقوله من كل هذه القصص
انه على مر السنوات والقصص كل مره كنا
بنشوف ردات فعل مختلفه من النوادي على
اتهامات لاعبيها بالاغتصاب او التحرش او
الاعتداء الجنسي والسؤال هنا لاي درجه
الانديه بتضرر لما نلاعبيها بيتهموا بقصص
مثل هذه حتى ولو ما اثبتت مثلا على
اللعيبه او لم يدانوا لاحقا وسؤال الثاني
هل هناك رده فعل معينه ممكن نقول انها
يعني النموذجيه او التعامل الصحيح لادارات
النوادي مع قصص مثل هذه خاصه وانه عالم
كره القدم تحديدا ونظرا طبعا للشهره
والفلوس والاضواء اللي فيه صرنا بنسمع عن
حوادث من هذا النوع للحديث اكثر في هذا
الموضوع بينضم الينا من القاهره الاعلاميه
والمحلل الرياضي اسر حسين اهلا فيك معانا
اسر ايش رايك الان في تعامل النادي مع
اشرف حكيمي خلينا نبتدي به النموذج او
المثال اللي عندنا اياه موجود الان
طيب برحب بك طبعا في برنامج المحترم
جمهورك يمكن الفكره مع اشرف حكيمي هو انه
التوقيت حدوث او توقيت الاتهام انه احنا
بنتكلم على واحد من اهم النجوم العرب مع
طبعا مناصفه مع محمد صلاح ومع حكيم زياش
النجوم العربي اللي شرفت الكره الاوروبيه
كمان هو دلوقتي بعد ايام او بعد فتره
قصيره من انجاز تحقيق المغرب لرابع العالم
والوصول لنصف النهائي لاول مره كاول فريق
عربي افريقي حق ده تبقى
الاتهام يبقى اتهام حتى يثبت ادانه المتهم
يعني كل اللي حصل انه انه ذهبت السيده دي
وقالت انه للبوليس وقالت ان السبت قبل
الماضي زي ما حضرتك قلت في المقدمه تم انه
كانت في منزله تم عمليه الاغتصاب وبالتالي
صرحت طبعا فاني كولين المحاميه بتاعه اشرف
حكيمي انه ده يبقى اتهام بس وان من خلال
توليها القضيه او الاتهام انه اللي جمع من
المعلومات من البوليس او
الشرطه القضائيه هناك هي بتعتبر انه حتى
الان هي عمليه ابتزاز واستغلال
النادي حتى الان
لا انا بشوف انه
الموضوع بياخد لازم نقول ان هو بياخد
مراحل انه حضرتك تطرحي سؤال النوادي
بتتعمل ازاي بعتقد انه بعد بعد اللي حصل
وكانت نجوم كبار هدف لاكثر من عمليه من ده
او تعرضت لانه كانوا بيتم اتهامهم بده ان
النوادي لازم تكون متاهبه لحاجه زي كده
انه وارد جدا يكون كل قوه فريق زي ما
الانجليز بيقولوا يعني الباد ابل او ان
لعيب او كانسان يقدم على حاجه زي دي سواء
بالتحرش الجنسي او بالاغتصاب وشفنا اكثر
من حاله فبالتالي النادي لازم يكون متاهب
لان المرحله الاولى زي ما باريس بيعمل
بعتقد زي ما حضرتك قلت انا بتفق معهم لانه
اللاعب حتى انه يثبت عليه شيء بيدمج فيه
السكواد او القائمه اللي رايحه تلعب في
مباراه مصريه في دوري الابطال والفريق
خسران على ارض افتراك دو برانس 1-0 يعني
محتاج انه يعوض الهزيمه عشان يصعد حتى
الان في البدايه بتحمل اللاعب بتاعك الى
ان يثبت عكس ده عندنا نموذج ثاني مهم جدا
نموذج مانشستر يونايتد اللي بر التزم
الصمت في قضيه اللعب اللي كان متهم متهام
مباشر بالاغتصاب الى ان ان صدر تسجيلات
على السوشيال ميديا بتوثق
تسجيلات صوتيه للي حصل اثناء عمليه
الاقتصاد فبالتالي كانت موجه عالمه الغضب
لما وقفوا راتبه واتخذوا القرارات كانوا
كانهم يعني ما كانوا دين رسميا كانوا
كانهم بيرفعوا يده يدهم منه انه ما لهم
دخل وبعدين هم تورطوا لما اسقطت عنه
الاتهامات يعني صار الوضع صعب الاتهامات
اسقطت هم مو قادرين يرجعوه الان يعني
حضرتك حاجه اللي حاصل دلوقتي انه بالضبط
هي المعضله دي هي انه هم ما بين او بالصدد
انه عايزين يرجعوا لعيب لان بالنسبه
لمانشستر يونايتد الموضوع بعتقد هيكون
اقتصادي بحت او الموضوع بتفكر فيه او
المكاسب ده للنادي بس لانه اللاعب عنده 21
سنه لو استرجع اللاعب ثاني او اعاده تعاقد
ما هيوفر حوالي 100 مليون استرليني في
لاعب كان السجل التهديفي بتاعه ممتاز جدا
واحد عناصر الشابه المنتخب انجلترا لكن
اديكي مثال على عنوانه تقرير كان نازل على
صحيفه اتلتيك بتقول انه لو رجع مانشستر
يونايتد جريند دي تبقى هزيمه لكره القدم
عنوان عنيف جدا بيؤكد حاله الغضب اللي
موجوده بانه فريق السيدات في في حتى الان
رافض او بيتكلم على انه مش يعني مش شايف
انه الاصح عوده اللاعب بعد ان ثبت عليه
اسقطت الاتهام صحيح لانه الضحيه تراجعت عن
التسجيلات او تم الضغط عليها لكن هم
عايزين يقولوا انه احنا بنتكلم على لاعب
اي
مده السجن او مده العقوبه لكنه اثبت عليه
انه ممكن يقدم على اغتصاب فبالتالي لا
يمكن ان يدمر ثاني داخل حتى اللاعب نفسه
بيفكر في خوض تجربه في الصين ان لم يعد
يونايتد
هو واضح انه جاي عليه عروض كثيره كمان
لصغر سنه يعني كمان في هذا الموضوع بس
خليني انتقل معك بالسريعا عشان الوقت
لنقطه اخرى
في التعامل بين الانديه العربيه والانديه
الاجنبيه يعني طبعا في القصه الشهيره اللي
عمرو ورده الي حتى تحول الموضوع وهو بيلعب
في المنتخب يعني باسم بلده واستمر هناك
بعتقد الضرر اللي حصل
وسؤال مهم جدا سؤال ذكي جدا اللي حصل في
قضيه عمرو ورده في 2019 وكانت مصر الدوله
منظمه لكاس امم افريقيا وظهر ما ظهر من
اللاعب التوهم بالتحرش او من خلال الرسائل
لاحد احد العرضات الازياء المصريين انه
الدعم اللي حصل من لعيبه كان دعم خاطئ جدا
لانه كان تاكد ساعتها انه اللاعب اقدم على
ده وكان نجوم فريق كبار في منتخب مصر
نزلوا حتى وصل الدعم الى دعم يعني او دعم
غير من غير حتى الرجوع الى حد او حتى
يستنوا انه تثبت براءته ورفعوا بالظبط غير
مشروط تماما ورفعوا تيشرت بتاعه كانه يعني
احد ابطال الفريق فبالتالي كان خطا كبير
جدا لانه بعد ده وبعد موجه عارمه من غضب
الجمهور المصري اضطر الاتحاد المصري
ساعتها برئاسه هاني ابو رضا انه استبعد
اللاعب خالص منتخب الوطني ومن اي انه ينضم
تاني لاحد المنتخبات الوطنيه حتى النادي
بتاعه فسخ التعاقد معه بيلعب في الدوري
القبرصي فبالتالي اعتقد التعامل كان سيء
جدا لانه كان بيمثل مصر ساعتها
وما كانش
الترويج الجيد لانه لاعب لما يحصل كده حتى
محمد صلاح نجمنا وفخر العرب يعني هجم انا
كنت في انجلترا في الوقت ده وفي لندن بشكل
كبير انه ازاي قبلت انك تكون معاه في نفس
الفريق او توافق انه ينضاف بعده
تلاحق وكل ما احد بده يهاجمه ويذكروا او
يسترجعوا له موقفه في قضيه عمرو ورده على
العموم احنا بنشكرك على هذه المداخله كان
معنا من القاهره الاعلامي والمحلل الرياضي
اسر حسين شكرا لك
[موسيقى]